[Music]
on this saturday night a public health
blitz
in bc how the province is cracking down
as covid 19 cases climb
and videos show large crowds in close
contact
a car bomb outside a courthouse police
in kitchener ontario update their
investigation
into a deadly explosion plus grounded
for good
navigating the future of boeing's
beleaguered 737
max planes and remembering victory while
honoring those
lost canada and its wartime allies
mark 75 years since the end of the
second world war
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
jeff semple
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight with concerns about
a resurgence of covid 19 in this country
and the efforts to stop the spread
particularly among younger canadians
the message to avoid large gatherings
doesn't seem to be getting through to
everyone
in british columbia the kovit 19 curve
is on pace to climb faster in september
than it did in march and the majority of
new infections
are among young adults in their 20s and
30s
so starting this weekend officials in bc
are keeping tabs on large gatherings
conducting spot checks at banquet halls
and other venues open to the public
ensuring that proper protocols and
physical distancing measures
are being followed but trying to limit
spontaneous gatherings in outdoor spaces
is proving a tougher challenge
global's nadia stewart joins us now from
vancouver where a video
of a late night street party is raising
eyebrows nadia
jeff there is mounting frustration
amongst health officials as it seems
some younger british colombians just
aren't getting the message
even as the number of cases continues to
climb
new videos show some are flouting
coveted 19 guidelines
this was the scene on granville street
in downtown vancouver in the early hours
of saturday morning
bar and club owners say when they reach
capacity they turn people
away but it seems some late night
revelers come prepared
with speakers and subwoofers launching
their own
impromptu street party vancouver police
say they
quickly broke up this gathering but
sources tell global news this scene
continued until
at least two or three o'clock in the
morning there is of course the risk of
transmission
but bars and clubs are also worried if
this continues
they could be shut down again and they
say many establishments
won't survive a second round of closures
unbelievably frustrating and
disappointing
people decided to have a street party
during a global pandemic i mean this is
serious
and that needs to be stringently
enforced
it's you're putting even police officers
who might try and enforce that at risk
from it
[Applause]
between the late night street parties
and drum circles in plain sight
efforts are being made to communicate
this urgent message to younger british
colombians
that physical distancing must be
maintained along with socializing
in much smaller groups than what's shown
here
actors ryan reynolds and seth rogen
answered premier john horgan's call to
get the message out to younger british
columbians
but some say what's needed now is more
enforcement
they're calling for a crackdown on those
caught ignoring the rules
back to you jeff nadia stewart in
vancouver thanks nadia
and front of mind for many parents right
now is the countdown to classes in
september with schools across the
country set to reopen
provinces and territories are releasing
their plans in saskatchewan premier
scott mo
just provided an update in a facebook
post ahead of a formal announcement
that's set for monday
the move comes after that province's
current reopening plan was met with
backlash
parents teachers even health care
professionals raising concerns
that the safe schools plan is anything
but gabriella penza beltrandi has more
jonathan lolard's daughters are two and
four his oldest will be starting school
in september the saskatoon dad says he
doesn't feel completely confident in the
province's safe schools plan right now
what's implemented at the moment i don't
think is enough
so if another round of ideas and
more precautions is probably going to
make me a little bit more at ease
the current strategy leaves a lot of
details up to the province's 27
school divisions to decide on their own
things like class sizes
how to separate students and one big
issue masks
many divisions have taken it upon
themselves to mandate masks for students
and teachers
protests were held across the province
last week calling for the ministry of
education to do more to protect students
i want to see change i want to see
thresholds for when we move to each
level
there has to be financial resources put
into cleaning
plexiglas smaller classrooms the
saskatchewan teachers federation says
some staff have asked if they can
legally refuse to work
why is it that only six people can sit
together at a table
in a restaurant and yet we can jam 30 or
35 students together with a teacher in a
you know a poorly ventilated classroom
premier scott mo is expected to announce
updates to the province's back to school
safety measures on monday
today he released a video on facebook
providing some details
we will be providing an additional 40
million dollars
so that our classrooms our students and
our staff are kept safe it's unclear
where that 40 million will come from
moe says the province is also working on
plans for voluntary covit 19 testing in
schools for staff
and students classes will start a week
later than usual on september 8th
but with details still up in the air
about what back to school will look like
for kids in saskatchewan more parents
are looking into homeschooling as an
alternative to classrooms this fall
so we'll just see how the things will go
and how the schools
will handle all these situations
gabriella panzel trendy global news
a new survey suggests canadian
restaurants could lose up to 20 billion
dollars in revenue over the next year
because of the pandemic felicia perillo
takes a look at the struggles for the
food and beverage industry
from montreal
bob harmony has been working at
lermanois restaurant and bar
for more than 45 years in all of his
time here he says
he's never quite experienced a year like
this one
i think less and less people are coming
out
having a beer in the bars with the big
screens and the big tvs people at home
have their own 50 inch tv now
and their own 2 beers at home the resto
bar is open for breakfast lunch and
dinner
it's used to big lineups a diverse
clientele
and a staff of about a hundred but owner
peter sergakis says since reopening
staff has been reduced by 75 percent
because clients are simply not coming
i mean listen the place looks like
inside looks like a cemetery
according to quebec statistics institute
from march to june of this year
the province lost about 450 000 jobs
365 000 of them were in the service
industry and more specifically
100 000 jobs were lost in the restaurant
and accommodation sector
those statistics are all too familiar
first aciondespar
located downtown montreal manager kim
shore says
they have about 10 percent of their
staff back on the job
she says there are multiple reasons for
the shortage
but the main one is lack of clients in
terms of revenue the bar is bringing in
about 15 to 20 percent
of what they did last year right now we
have
hockey basketball is starting the
playoffs we have the championship league
soccer
and normally all these games are places
packed
lineups to get in reservations
the most recent data from july 20th
shows that 65 montrealers have been
confirmed to have been infected with
covet 19
in a bar sergakis says people are simply
hesitant
to visit restaurants and bars and it
shows
the habits change people are getting
more
they start enjoying themselves staying
home
and if there is a small risk if they go
out they don't want to take it
sergakis and his employees say at this
point they can't see the light at the
end of the tunnel
they believe things will only get worse
before it gets any better
felicia perello global news montreal
to the united states now where many
businesses and schools across the
country are reopening
even as case numbers climb more than 5.3
million people in the u.s have now
tested positive since the start of the
pandemic
and there are now more than 600 thousand
cases in california alone making it the
first state to hit that milestone
but as covet 19 cases rise the number of
daily tests
are dropping jennifer johnson explains
health officials in the u.s are
reporting a troubling trend
a two-week drop in covet 19 testing
experts say delays at testing stations
in at least 34 states
are keeping americans away risking
people unknowingly spreading the virus
six seven months into a pandemic the
fact that we can't
test people reliably is shameful
medical experts are pushing for more
widespread testing
after reports up to 40 percent of people
with the virus do not show symptoms
patients say while testing wait times
are long waiting for results is even
longer
i got my tests on july 1st and i didn't
get the results until july 21st
the american medical association is
pushing for new fast track testing
to quickly pinpoint potential hot spots
meanwhile as schools reopen
cases are spiking at the university of
north carolina which opened last week
clusters of outbreaks have already shown
up in at least two dorms
i think the university needs to have
more clear communication with us about
where in our building it is so that we
feel we do feel safer
in florida a judge friday refused to
dismiss a teacher's union lawsuit
against the state over reopening
as governor ron desantis threatens to
cut off funding for schools that don't
we're going to
rip open the doors and put masks on kids
and
hope for the best children we are in
charge of their safety
teachers being forced to go back are
still protesting across the country
we feel that there are some some pretty
irresponsible practices going on that
threaten the safety and health of
primarily again the student fear and
anxiety gripping the nation
as the covet 19 death toll is on the
verge of surpassing
170 thousand people jennifer johnson
global news washington new quarantine
rules for travelers entering the uk
kicked in today prompting a rush of
british tourists scrambling home to beat
the deadline
some with just minutes to spare in
france
thousands of britons jammed tunnel
crossings train stations and airports
after the uk announced thursday that
anyone traveling from france needs to
quarantine for 14 days
that rule came into effect at four
o'clock local time this morning
those who fail to quarantine face fines
of up to a thousand pounds
an update now on the investigation into
that deadly blast in beirut the fbi has
now sent a team to lebanon to join the
probe into the massive explosion that
devastated the capital
the move follows an invitation by
lebanese authorities
seeking answers into the blast at the
port of beirut earlier this month that
killed more than 170 people and wounded
thousands more
the fbi team joins investigators from
france
trying to determine what sparked a fire
that caused more than 2 700 tons of
ammonium nitrate to explode
and in a statement released friday
justin trudeau confirmed two canadians
were among those victims killed by that
explosion the prime minister offered his
deepest condolences to family and
friends of the two canadians
adding his thoughts are also with other
canadians who were injured
or still missing still ahead police
provide an update into the improvised
explosive device that erupted
outside an ontario courthouse
welcome back an investigation is
underway tonight into a deadly blast
outside an ontario courthouse a vehicle
exploded yesterday in downtown kitchener
just west of toronto
killing the man inside police are still
trying to figure out exactly what
happened but as morgan campbell explains
they believe that blast may have been
caused by an improvised
explosive device anytime you have
an event like that happen in any
community it's always
a period of concern people across
kitchener ontario
are still comprehending the scene
outside their city's courthouse
friday after an explosive device went
off
inside a parked car it's pretty wild
that it would happen like so close to
home
the blast transforming this normally
peaceful area
into a massive security effort one man's
body was discovered
inside the car waterloo regional police
say
he brought the bomb to the courthouse
but the reason for the detonation
is unclear officers can't say if there
was an intended target
we do understand public concern over
this
and our investigators are working very
diligently
and around the clock to try and
determine the motive following the
explosion police spent
hours searching two homes both in
kitchener
they say the residences are connected to
the man in the car
and they are not looking for any other
suspects
neighbors tell global news the man had
recently moved to a home on hearthwood
drive to live with his parents
following a separation those details
have not been
independently confirmed by global news
obviously a tragedy for the for the
individual involved and and for their
family
but it's also a reminder for all of us
that the last four or five months have
been difficult for
uh for many people in in in different
ways and
and the importance for us to reflect on
our own well-being but also to checking
on others
police say the investigation is moving
quickly as they work to
determine a motive however they say
there
is no concern for public safety morgan
campbell
global news the longtime leader of the
mohawk council of gonawage has died
grand chief joseph norton passed away
yesterday after falling in his home
he served as gonowage's grandchief for
nearly three decades
norton was known across north america as
a fierce defender of mohawk rights
he played a prominent role in the 1990
oka crisis
and the rail blockades earlier this year
norton
was 70. thousands of accounts with the
canada revenue agency have been breached
by
cyber attacks hackers were able to
access about 5 500 accounts using a
technique called
credential stuffing it relies on
databases of previously stolen login
information
the agency has now disabled access to
all of those accounts
more than 9 000 others linked to the gc
key service which provides access to
government services online
have also been affected anyone who was
hacked should update their passwords
immediately
and avoid reusing any old passwords the
cra is investigating and has also asked
the rcmp
for help still ahead a major setback in
the efforts to contain
this environmental disaster in mauritius
you're watching global national
well an update now on that major
environmental disaster off mauritius
the japanese carrier that ran aground
and spilled around 1 000 tons of oil
has now split in two the larger part of
that vessel is being towed away
and a spokesperson for the island's
shipping ministry says the other section
which contains the engine and the fuel
tanks
is quote safe and stable and measures
have now been taken to stop any further
oil from leaking
and polluting the area's pristine coral
reefs
the covet 19 pandemic has caused an
unprecedented pause
in air travel the number of worldwide
passengers is expected to be cut
in half compared to last year and the
crisis is added to the
woes of boeing the airline manufacturer
is still hoping to get its 737
max aircraft re-certified to fly again
following two deadly crashes that
grounded the entire fleet
as redmond shannon explains the perfect
storm of events
is expected to make for a turbulent
return
the boeing 737 is the workhorse of the
skies
the best selling passenger jet ever when
the more efficient 737
max was launched it was an instant hit
airlines placed
5 000 orders hundreds were delivered
that was until two crashes five months
apart
they were caused by a software flaw and
grounded the entire fleet
in the second ethiopian airlines crash
18 canadians died
among the 346 victims of the two
tragedies
and the imagination of what your loved
ones suffered during those final moments
they just never go and and i have to
live with that
all max planes remain on the ground as
boeing works to
recertify the modified aircraft and
retrain pilots
but now there is a global pandemic the
un's civil aviation body icao estimates
air travel in 2020 has fallen off at
cliff
with passenger numbers set to drop by at
least 50 percent
compared with last year i think it's
going to cope with
uh dramatically reduced deliveries in
the near term
and obviously we've had some massive
layoffs
at boeing and airbus and those may
continue
so far boeing has seen more than 400
cancelled max
orders this year when you include orders
at risk
a major issue because of covid19 that
number more than doubles
and it could get worse the problem that
boeing has
is their contract indicated that if they
couldn't deliver airplanes within a
year of the of the scheduled timing uh
the customer could walk away from any or
all of that
of that order it's critical that that by
the first quarter next year the 737 max
get back into the air
otherwise many airlines might swap to
competing airbus aircraft
fearing that passengers will be hesitant
to fly in a max
what no one knows yet is what the
consumer's reaction is going to be to
the max regaining trust will be one
thing
but the great unknown is covert 19 and
how long the pandemic
could eat into the demand for the 737
max
redland shannon global news london
for the first time in nearly 20 years
california has ordered statewide
rolling power outages hundreds of
thousands of people were left in the
dark last night for roughly an hour at a
time
those rotating blackouts were needed
because of an increased energy demand
temperatures there are hovering around
35 degrees celsius across the state
sparking a surge in air conditioning use
that heat is expected to stick around
through next week
and more outages could happen as early
as today california hasn't had rolling
blackouts since 2001.
and that california heat wave is also
causing problems for firefighters
crews are battling three major wildfires
burning near los angeles
they're working in steep rugged terrain
and scorching temperatures
the lake fire is the largest blaze it's
destroyed at least 21 buildings and is
now threatening more than 5 000 homes
there's concern those high temperatures
and low humidity levels
could spark new fires over the weekend
up next marking the end of the second
world war
75 years later
wartime allies held commemorations to
mark the victory over japan
or vj day the official end of the second
world war
exactly 75 years ago the british royal
family led a special remembrance for the
tens of thousands of soldiers
including those from across the uk
canada and the united states
who fought and died during the campaign
together they comprised a force whose
courage
was as remarkable as its diversity
together they served with the greatest
distinction without them
the war could not have been won
and a service in ottawa honored the 10
000 canadians who fought in asia and
tens of thousands more who joined the
pacific forces
they formed part of the final allied
push to victory
before the armistice was declared on
this day in 1945
just days after the united states
dropped two atomic bombs on hiroshima
and nagasaki
[Music]
and that is global national for this
saturday i'm jeff semple tonight's your
canada is the
village of disney saskatchewan northwest
of regina
if you'd like to share your canada with
us please email your photos to viewers
at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you back
here again tomorrow have a great
[Music]
[Applause]
night